[Music]
indoor cam distress news Oh No yes will
happen submitted by the JK life what is
that you know what that is
the eat work out and then go film it's
come up with crazy scenarios with your
friends oh that's true because not
everybody works out and you still take
sip one life one life sitting you take
sip you [ __ ] yourself with it right yes
this is new news tell them what you said
when you took your first sip of this I
would literally [ __ ] myself with this
I haven't logistical II found out how
but coming soon freeze it building soon
fuse dildo what cat happy and for your
[ __ ] or that I wanted coffee enema have
you seen the ashes watcher enema March I
thought I was talking about where you
could put ashes in the glass dildo you
could put that drink in that - of a dead
person but we need the cat being a reach
to [ __ ] so it stays on was like a slow
diffuses my [ __ ] don't sleep no die but
your pussy's [ __ ] stay woke down about
the [ __ ] calm down I'm not sad I was
just imagining a [ __ ] with sunglasses
that's dancing
[Laughter]
Flint was the nose so it's like caffeine
when you said that your [ __ ] stays woke
I feel like it's your [ __ ] holding up
like a political sign or some [ __ ] or
another protesting protest yeah I
pictured a blue guy yeah [ __ ] glasses
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] up eyebrows in a
blunt cut like [ __ ] things and she's
[ __ ] offended by everything yeah hmm
yeah that's our model always like this a
[Laughter]
woman who was taped in a door bought cam
video looking for help and shackles is
defending her attacker Oh No Oh did you
see that
she was mad by roll yes viral I roll
knew your attacker
you know like boyfriends have beat their
girls the girls like no he's nice leave
him alone when you try to rescue no no
he loves me oh wait what like she's not
defending herself she's defending the
guy that beat oh my god so what was the
story to get beat some more ladies this
cuz I remember like they found out who
the lady was because it was like a
domestic abuse whatever right oh so she
knows her attacker
so her attacker is her boyfriend and
she's defending him after she got her
ass beat baby died he died
yeah okay I want to hear the full story
in sequential order peace you I'm trying
to tell you he died a nutty beaver dog
mom tell her to stop that's because we
did this Jake a news article before but
there's a follow-up no we did it
are you sure I remember what we've done
sometimes but it wasn't this story we
haven't done the story me hear it in
sequential order without anyway
interrupting please Julia [ __ ] Julia
so rude Jesus Christ
all right go okay so this woman just 32
year old woman she this all went viral
because a family who noticed on their
door cam footage that this woman late at
night she went to their door
I started banging on the door and then
you could see she had shackles around
her wrists she was only wearing a
t-shirt no pants and she looked like in
distress and so police started this like
investigation investigation trying to
find out who this woman was
I'm not too sure exactly how they found
out who she was but it turned out that
she had been sexually assaulted that
night by her boyfriend and there's
multiple camp photos because she went to
multiple homes oh it was really late she
was also trying to wave cars down but
nobody help me help me
yeah so this time we live in dude yeah
cuz sometimes I wouldn't be scared of a
pantsless girl with handcuffs no there's
some there's people those stories of
like there's like a woman in distress
and when you stop all you do is jump out
and like jump you and steal your car the
one who runs up to you're a public space
and saying oh my god this guy's
following me can you drive me home so
you drive her home and there's like 15
dudes waiting yeah they do those are
those are apocalypse moves and they did
that a Book of Eli remember oh really I
thought they'd do that with dogs too
like you see a lost dog and you try to
help it and then like it leads you to
those dudes
well they train the dog to get kidnapped
so hard if it was a dog see that why be
what if you kept the dog and then you
went home and then now they were crying
cuz their dog got stoled
we're poochy poochy I'm so dumb like
Ellis across the street my girlfriend's
house at night and I saw a cat on a lawn
like a cross street so I walked up to
the cats to try to play with it ran like
like I kept I'm trying to follow it then
I realize I'm almost like in front this
person's house I'm like damn I don't get
kidnapped so hard yeah to be a woman is
so scary
it is me because no no I've see Worman
then you don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
that that's the thing is I would like to
be a violent woman because also my
chemistry is different is [ __ ] so like I
don't have the violent tendencies and
then it's like so but if I was then I
would use my looks as like a way to like
lure my [ __ ] prey you know I mean but
then like I'm not gonna be as strong so
I don't know what that feels like I just
have to carry a knife you just said it
like a man though yeah like girls aren't
usually looking for praise Tallulah I
mean though so like if I was in the mind
of a girl right like like then it would
be different yeah we're just I just feel
like everyone's trying to break me all
that exactly everything that's how
you're raised to believe everyone's just
out to rape you exactly we only got to
worry about robbery
true yeah you know I gotta worry about
rape and see you a killer
my grandmother tried to scare me when I
was like 5 years old she's like you
better be careful or a list of something
oh my god Asian people herself 20 years
later you're [ __ ] following a stray
cat inside no survival skills but you
know like all old Asian bears are super
racist she was like don't go to bla bla
bla because a black guy was gonna kidnap
you and he's gonna chop you up and put
you in the fridge and I'm like that's
why people 85 is white people that is
white people got all the racism
wrong I understand how you got that but
okay whatever but here I want to be
kidnapped by a black person if I had to
choose because there are other chopping
tires there with fit tire like I don't
even even they're twisted you're like
Asians will kidnap you and then like
sell your [ __ ] organs and Mexicans
they'll kidnap you and stuff cocaine in
your body and make you deliver it and
why did why if you will just do it for
fun and like [ __ ] like you don't hear
a black idea but a black guy would
kidnap you and maybe like call for
ransom yeah you know it's like normal
crime you know like and of all the races
which one do you think it's the least
likely to rape least likely to rape the
women race the one race I think Ray
penis is in all of them because - I
think I think we're really asking it so
rape is all of them right but rape and
then get eaten or rape and they get
beaten or rape and they get carved up
and chopped legged you have to focus on
the other part cuz everyone gets right
cuz I didn't think that Indian dudes
were so rapey oh dude because because in
America the way I see Indians is like
upper class and engineers and smart
dudes and whatever right but then like
in India a lot of [ __ ] be going down
hill of raping over there yeah no matter
where I am I just don't want to [ __ ]
with Russians I feel like they'll do
something Cory maybe [ __ ] to themselves
you know what I just came across the
craziest [ __ ] story that it was just
too crazy talk anyway
no this Russian kid this teenage Russian
gamer kitty oh yeah this computer game
he went outside he got a chainsaw
[ __ ] chains on his own head off
that's [ __ ] crazy
oh yeah oh damn Russia's like a country
psychopath venez dad was proud of him
too Russian Yuri I have five kids and
they all chop off their own heads when
they lose at video games
yeah dude he started up a chainsaw and
just like damn that's [ __ ] crazy okay
anyway this effect of this woman that
haven't liked them though because
they're crazy like that you knew for ten
years not girl I this there's all this
[ __ ] that always gets revealed here like
he's like slowly leaking all these
things cuz now I can't run away anymore
she learns more about her husband and JK
news that she's ever had any other time
really yeah you knew all these no I did
it what do you mean
literally what I said true cuz weed will
you have that conversation
alright cuz it doesn't make same any
sense like I knew that about him because
we will have that conversation but when
you're dating someone you don't go you
ever thought about killing someone right
yeah we're not gonna go to that
conversation with him house guys guys
imagine things right so we're just
talking about random like there's time
girls imagine no I mean Joe were broke
as [ __ ]
oh yeah shooting on three megapixel
cameras like imagine we had our own
movie put night that's all guys talk
that's normal yeah girls know but we
don't we don't hold hands that [ __ ]
sugar fish and I go you know if a kid
chopped his head off that's kind of cool
I would never talk to you about that
that would never be a romantic you're
like dating moon
Oh is mine words what do you mean your
why him know who you are as a person she
does know late now she's thought you do
know but what I'm saying that there was
an opportunity for that to happen
because of the conversation that happens
but it's obvious that the opportunity is
here at JK do you know what it is he
hides himself for me no you can't take
that back after the pink eye story so
that after that you have no credibility
of the relationship go cell for me
sometimes I wish you would though so
what's going on here with that [ __ ]
sorry I'm sorry sorry sorry sorry
I was just mad because she was
protecting the abuser yeah that's me so
much window imagine you see a dude
beating girl and you gonna be able to
dude she's like no stop it's yeah you
know like that's what I'm mad let me
show you guys this video of her talking
about this don't wanna go into lot of
details but I was scared at the time and
that's what caused me to read
that she was in fear for her safety she
says afraid of her boyfriend Dennis
Collins with whom she was living I
believe in my heart that is not you who
truly is oh boy
it hurts me to see him online
she said I'm bashing your head the
doorbell video was circulated around the
world on social media until this
Wednesday when police called her parents
to inform her that Dennis Collins had
taken his own life I was okay and I
didn't know it but it gave me the
strength to save either the comments
made him kill himself no I think he's I
don't know since they saw her on camera
they didn't he knew the cops were coming
what small begin happened this girl's
gonna end up in another similar
relationship that's what I was thinking
is like um you know guys like that go
for girls like this you go for the ones
that don't fight back it's so sad I know
because when I get a go that don't fight
back I get so bored I'm just like you
need to be with a serial killer
I mean verbally fight back both OH
fire uh-huh you enemy you ingested his
fist fighting at home in the living room
it's a ring that's my dream oh brother
so this dude's brother was saying that
they were having kinky sex night night
off [ __ ] off and then his brother so
this dude also has a daughter I'm not
sure how old she is how does his brother
know great I don't know I heard him up
there they were [ __ ] whole but then
so he said that he killed himself not
out of guilt but because he couldn't
stand his daughter thinking of him that
way and because he had been unhappy for
a long time and proved her wrong that's
what the brother said first of all I've
got kinky sex before and all that [ __ ]
you don't see me running to my
neighbor's house yeah
I stay the [ __ ] back I mean I pretend I
run yeah what's his idea of sex
handcuff her and beat her up he pleaded
guilty of sexual sexually abusing
another woman about two decades earlier
yeah it's a piece of [ __ ] I bet you he
like does some weird [ __ ] like
electrocutes our [ __ ] or something I've
seen those yeah I've seen that why these
electric ones it's interesting I'm gonna
cover Internet some people like to
torture people and they get horny yeah
not people like to get tortured in that
next morning I've been to like BDSM
clubs and like TFT I I know you soon
remember how like when we fire dance and
stuff you know it goes hand in hand oh
it does someone want a fire [ __ ] and
I would be like people strapped to like
the X like a giant X and then like
they're women I'm they're whipping hard
dude like Jesus Christ I should hardly I
want the opposite put me on an X and
lick me all red like their butts turn
already [ __ ]
[Music]